GOOGLE CLOUD NEXT '20: ON AIR
WHAT'S NEXT
HIDDEN FORCES:
WHAT'S NEXT IN ENTERPRISE IT
Hello, and thanks for tuning in
to the final keynote of Next OnAir 2020.
Today I'm going to talk to you
about the upcoming revolution in cloud
one of the rare cases
where picking the right path today
helps you both in the short term
and over the next two decades.
But first a bit of background,
so bear with me for a few minutes.
I'm Urs Hölzle.
And in my 21 years of leading
the technical infrastructure teams at Google
I have had the good fortune
to work with many
of the world's smartest engineers
software developers, and business leaders.
Not just at Google
but at customers, our partners
and in academia
and the open-source community.
Working together, we've been able to take on
one of the biggest problems in IT,
the sorry state of enterprise innovation.
The sad fact is today
much of enterprise IT is like a dinosaur
big but slow and in danger of dying out.
And we see all the innovation
that consumers enjoy
and we wonder, why can't we have that too?
So it's easy to get depressed
about the future of IT
and worry about its extinction.
But it wasn't always like this.
When I was a teenager,
back in the last millennium
the best technology for
pretty much anything was in the enterprise.
Big companies
had the best computers, the best databases
even the best cameras.
But starting about 25 years ago, around 1995
something extraordinary happened.
For the first time ever
consumers began to enjoy innovation
at an unprecedented speed
literally unheard of in human history.
Enterprise technology,
always the leader in the past
began to fall behind.
Consumers got webmail, search,
internet maps, cloud-based storage
and then machine learning, real-time video,
awesome user experiences, automated backups
products that just kept getting better.
Enterprise technology, meantime,
continued at its old, slower pace.
What caused this reversal
in technology leadership?
Do consumers spend more on technology now
and enterprises spend less?
No.
Did consumer software engineers
become much more talented?
No.
Is there a magic quantum hyperspace
innovation accelerator
that only works for consumer products?
Of course not.
What did happen was a new way
of seeing and building technology
and for a long time,
the enterprise has missed that way.
With the invention of the web
there was a programming surface,
HTML
that allowed
any application developer or SaaS vendor
to deliver software to any customer,
and all these customers look the same.
They all run on the same platform.
And then 10 years ago
with Android and iPhone
the same thing happened to phones.
In both cases, the stacks auto-update
so everyone is on the same version
of the same stack all the time.
No different versions,
just a single powerful experience
usually on open standards
for maximum velocity.
And with this approach
developers spend more time
on programming
without having to deal with a myriad
of different versions at customers.
They can use practices
like continuous deployment and integration
which rolls out small releases
more frequently
starting with small sets of users
to make sure they're safe.
They find bugs with
the first percent of users and fix them fast.
And then the new release
can go out to all users.
And that's low risk because they're all
on the same version of the stack.
Let's pause here for a second
because this is the crucial point.
If we find bugs early in the rollout
with 1% of users
then to the rest of the users
it looks like the bug rate
is 100 times smaller.
Services just work with a hundred times
higher perceived quality
so there's no need to fear upgrades
and it's no wonder that consumers
don't demand to qualify new releases
before they're installed.
They assume they work
because they almost always do.
So the obvious question is
why hasn't this happened for the enterprise?
Why are even companies that move to the cloud
often dissatisfied
with their rate of innovation
the quality of
their operational visibility or their security?
It's because enterprises are in a tough spot.
We all use similar hardware and software
but we integrated them differently
and we all have our own version matrix.
So it's mostly similar stuff on a macro level
but each arrangement
is as unique as a snowflake.
So each enterprise is a snowflake
with its own unique version mix.
So when I'm a SaaS vendor
trying to update a new customer
it's literally the first time
I'm deploying that update
into exactly this environment.
So everyone is nervous about the update
because things tend to break
on the first attempt.
And even after I've updated
10,000 other companies
the next one is like the first time
because it's a new snowflake.
So my software quality
doesn't look great to the customer.
Updates are expensive,
and they're slow and infrequent.
So it's the snowflake that's killing
the enterprise dinosaur.
And if we don't get rid of snowflakes
enterprise innovation is going to be doomed
because we cannot evolve,
just like the dinosaurs.
These snowflakes have made
an enormous difference
to the slope of the innovation curve.
When you assume just a 20%
additional friction from snowflakes
compounded over 25 years
that's a factor of 100.
That's why consumer innovation
has surged ahead.
So what is the answer?
How can we allow enterprises
to each create
their own unique value proposition
but with automation,
scale, and standardization
at consumer-like speed?
Well, the enterprise needs
a software platform that is always up to date
where everyone uses exactly the same stack,
so updates see exactly the same environment.
It needs to be open-source
so improvements can happen
in any environment, with no vendor login.
And the platform needs
to accommodate legacy systems too
because nobody can afford
to rewrite everything.
And it needs to run on-prem
and in any cloud, wherever you want it.
This platform exists today.
It's seeing impressive enterprise adoption
and its name is Anthos.
We introduced Anthos a year ago at Next.
And since then we've been working closely
with a number of
developers, partners, and customers
to make it even stronger and more capable.
Recently, an independent study showed
an almost 5-times ROI when deploying Anthos.
That's not just an improvement.
It's a small revolution.
Anthos integrates
dozens of open-source packages
including Kubernetes containers
and provides them as a fully managed stack
not just on GCP, but across many clouds
in your on-premise data center
and at the edge.
It's based on open-source APIs,
making it for clouds
what the Linux operating system
was for servers 20 years ago
a safe choice to avoid locking,
with a rich ecosystem
and plenty of developers who know it.
Using Anthos, you can keep
your server hardware
your cloud provider of choice
and run pretty much anything on top of it.
That's as true for enterprises
with on-prem services and mainframes
as it is for companies
that were born in the cloud.
What all this gets you is the ability
to develop software
faster than ever before
to bring to your enterprise
the kind of speed of innovation
normally associated
only with consumer-oriented companies.
But Anthos goes beyond
just making it easier to write new software.
It helps you operate
and secure existing applications.
The fact is most enterprises
don't have the time or energy
to rewrite their existing applications.
So you need a platform that meets you
where you are today
with a complex mix of third-party
and home-grown applications
commercial and open-source
and helps you bring
those systems into the future.
And Anthos can help there as well.
In fact, I'd argue
Anthos is even more valuable
for existing applications.
Take just one example, Java apps.
Organizations often have hundreds
or even thousands
of Java enterprise applications.
These applications
are important to the business
but get relatively little attention
because they're mature.
So they languish until they become
so difficult to maintain
that they have to be rewritten from scratch.
Now, in the fastest case,
with Anthos' migration tools
you can take those apps
and migrate them automatically
moving them to containers.
You can keep these containers on-prem
or move to the cloud.
That's your choice.
But you see an immediate return
because you're reducing infrastructure
and licensing costs
and you have lower operating
and maintenance costs too
because Anthos make it simple to run,
monitor, secure and update applications.
You can even apply these
same migration techniques to Windows apps
enabling you to bring
legacy Windows Server apps to containers.
This includes Windows Server 2008,
which recently reached end of support.
A study conducted by Forrester found
that using Anthos
application migrations
were 58% to 75% faster.
Platform operating efficiency
improved up to 55%.
And productivity for security tasks
improved up to 75%.
But Anthos is not a dead end where
you park old applications.
For the apps you continue to develop
Anthos makes it easy to adopt
modern cloud-native development practices
including automated testing and deployment
reducing the time it takes
your development teams
to safely roll out new versions.
You even get the ability
to secure your software supply chain
with automated security analysis
such as vulnerability scanning
and secure assigned binaries.
This kind of speed
with stability and security
is what enables consumer-oriented companies
to be so innovative.
And with Anthos, you can have that too.
And every step of the way
your operations team gets new insight
into systems performance and reliability
including the ability to set and monitor
service-level objectives
as well as getting a comprehensive view
of your application dependencies.
All of this comes from using a system
that encapsulates the best practices
learned from our own decades of experience
in running containers at scale,
going all the way back to 2006
when we first brought containers
into the Linux kernel.
And we've distilled all this learning
and experience into Anthos
so your teams can follow practices
that have stood the test of time.
And this is not just a future possibility.
It is available today.
In a previous keynote,
you heard about how organizations
as diverse as the bank HSBC,
the retailer HEB, Telegraph Media Group
and Major League Baseball
are all using Anthos.
And of course, we're using it ourselves
to bring our marquee analytic service
to data stored in AWS
with BigQuery Omni
that was announced a few weeks ago.
Anthos is seeing broad uptake
in the enterprise.
That's testimony to both the proven
open-source products inside Anthos
and the work done at Google
and the great results
that enterprises are seeing.
All of this changes
how you should see cloud.
And it's not really about
the big three clouds, as most people think.
Now, let me go back to history
to explain what I mean.
In the 1990s, enterprise faced the new world
of PCs, workstations, and servers.
And they agonized over choosing HP,
Sun, Compaq, or someone else.
It was a big deal,
because once they chose one
they got the vendor's OS,
compilers, databases.
Everything was different.
That was the world in 1995.
But less than a decade later,
everyone realized
there were just two choices that mattered.
Not server companies, but operating systems:
Linux and Windows Server.
That's the choice that stayed
with you for two decades.
And of these two, open-sourced Linux
became a powerful standard.
And it has become more central
to enterprise computing
every single year since then.
Anthos offers the same
open-source answer for cloud
across on-premise data centers,
hybrid environments
single or multi-cloud,
and even telco edge environments.
Choosing Anthos is like choosing Linux.
Multi-platform, more economical,
more innovative, open
lower risk, at lower cost.
Choosing Anthos helps
enterprise developers
write amazing new modern applications
but it also gives brownfield applications
an incremental path to connect
to a rich future.
Some applications
can even be migrated automatically.
But most importantly,
Anthos can be adopted incrementally
one step at a time with low risk.
Now, some in the industry have argued
that this kind of portability
degrades the cloud experience
or leads to a least common
denominator approach.
They want you to stay inside
one cloud all the time.
But in fact, it's the opposite
because Anthos standardizes things
that do not differentiate
your business operations.
When developers do not have to learn
everything from scratch
when there is one way to develop, operate
and secure your workloads on any cloud
you can focus on value-adding activities.
You're free to choose the best-in-class tools
and services that are right for you
and if those needs change,
you don't have to start over from scratch.
So you could take advantage
of best-in-class offerings, wherever they are
because you are not deeply locked
in to one provider via provider-specific APIs
for all the minutiae required
to make things work.
Your configs, your load balancing,
your service management
they're the same everywhere.
So when you have to learn something new
it's because you chose
a unique service to use
not because you have to learn again
how to perform common tasks
in a new cloud
just to get to the unique service
that you want.
So Anthos maximizes your ability
to take advantage
of unique cloud functionality.
I can't stress enough how big a change
this will be in the industry
because, until now, adopting cloud
meant choosing a vendor
being locked in, having only one choice,
and having a heck of a hard time
integrating with
existing on-premise services.
No longer.
Anthos revives enterprise computing
with an open, auto-updating software stack
for the next 20 years.
And unlike previous shifts in technology
Anthos doesn't require
an architectural forklift.
It doesn't force you to rewrite.
It's one of the rare cases
where it's strategically the right choice
but also easy to adopt
with same-year benefits
for your developers and operators.
We're seeing our Anthos customers thrive,
not just with Anthos itself
but with a rich and growing ecosystem
of products, services, partners,
and tools and best practices.
Some have traditionally focused IT
others are on the cutting edge
of modern microservices.
But all are getting better security,
cost savings, better budget control
and much higher developer velocity.
So we look forward to more of you
joining this proven new era of innovation.
And we're eager to help you get started.
Be sure to catch our live keynote Q&A
where we'll address top-of-mind questions
from this discussion.
Thank you.